gerunds ran on the floor for the magic
lucha [ __ ] keeps it in and a foul on
Dwyane Wade watch this contact once
you've just guide the basketball in but
another terrific past inbound pass to
Jonathan Isaac watch the screen nice
dish to vote of it that's what you have
to do there that is a great job by Evan
foreign second defender if it's
Whiteside even better
there's the food's nice job move like it
pushes it quickly to wade nature gets
takes it away from it what a great job
by reach he's had a great first day of
offense Sandler picks him up on a switch
that's Vukovich waits a bit count the
basket and a fine when the crowd
murmuring let's watch it her and see
what the crowd was moaning about here's
the plan then the extra step I think
he's good on that one
sorry pooch of its kind of hand on that
one
Augustine's out the four and yay for
free
he thrills it the view with Dante now to
clean those up got know where people are
especially the best shooters when injury
pads and butch events will have a
three-point opportunity if you enter in
you gotta pass away from the defender
seemed taken to that outs threw it into
a crowd picked off by Orlando advanced
break basketball for the magic Isaac
hammers it down this one rebounded by
Isaac [ __ ] sit in [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
Bernays firstly today each of its two
flex to pass intended for college Stein
three-on-two Isaac hi getting a piece of
that one and then the magic shop the
outlet out and running again box he is
so quick features its beats him though
on the pink and the blue loose ball is
picked up by Augustine the foul is on
here self possession let's see if blue
chickens could make something happen
with the shot clock ticking down he can
be consistent with the call so the
players got used to it and gotten used
to it yeah no butch a [ __ ] and a foul
Gillis have a hot fourth quarter he
he'll try leaning into boots who
practice [ __ ] it's out of bounds magic
ball let's get another look here
so block by root food defense
that one off he was in a crowd and still
managed it that one this one David got
everybody excited pooch driving left
finishing over Andre Drummond two four
six in Game seven the decisive Game
seven there were four for six on threes
against Boston in the first round series
Mucha been scores again time ticking
down pooch events for three just have to
get back to executing on the offensive
end
bucho pitch for the work count the
basket and a foul food says give me the
ball it's just a nice job
strong move with the left hand Ingram is
gonna come in try to get a piece of it
the pooch strong forecast 29
[Music]
[Applause]
bucho [ __ ] for three that's a big shot
by Nicola butcher another strong
performance Augustine feeds futa [ __ ]
for the swap left-handed hook
get it to go rebound bucho [ __ ] now
Augustine one of the fast break for the
magic food Tibbets running the floor
beautifully pooch wicked boots starting
this break getting out wide Davis
sprinting the floor and finishing with a
left hand
gonna pull it out give it the boot back
inside the Jay Sims wide open and the
magic can't believe for the first time
in the game attention in there is Gordon
48 back to boots quick kick out the
sinners three-point shot for Jonathan
Center that is terrific ball movement
that time the magic 12 go 14 points per
game sets up an easy two points for Evan
Fournier Lawson bounced to loose
something up to look back big-time shot
by the cooler boots of it running the
offense through Gooch down the stretch
against Augustin great job by Egypt
Simmons holding his ground pooch if it's
with the block it's a clock violation on
Portland for a terrific defense right
here while CJ's gonna cross back over
and boot step enough to get that one
make that 2 for 11 from the floor
42 pooch here's a good scoring
opportunity nice footwork lukovitch's
what's in it
Augustine gets the screams from hooch
swamp tux on the left-hand input by
Nicola Vucinic for content and foots of
it's with a nice left-handed look the
magic up in this second quarter for the
magic booth 11 in the game
bucho bits down the middle moves it down
on white side so the quarter
Simmons hooch of its would be clock
ticking down at the buzzer
I'm right here shot clock going down not
a whole lot of room good defender on a
pooch pulling up the little fade away a
dozen points for the cola boot surface
that was up get a piece of it and she's
doing a good job keeping them out of the
base second-chance opportunities with
the shot clock ticking down
bucho bits gonna have to do something
quickly and he does a lot of switching
going on out there let's see
screen by Lopez the beam goes around it
attack e lucha [ __ ] who blocks it out
of bounds grant former bull the bucho
[ __ ] spinning man hitting talk about
skill of a big man in the second quarter
in Mexico City
Nikola boots a [ __ ] the first to double
digit scoring in this one he's got ten
Orlando in front Gordon who is struggled
from the floor for Vuckovich and a three
is good of the magic take the lead in
rusev ish lucha [ __ ] gets it
for gay back boots of itch God and
Orlando takes a two point lead for 89 15
to shoot for Mitchell and he's blocked
by bucho [ __ ] magic takeover and
Jonathan Simmons is foul 578 dumb
driving on boots or it's blocked by
boots
[Applause]
which got him again the block from
behind on window
[Applause]
augustin behind the bang the two-handed
Jam and then you got numbers challenge
the big drop it off Simmons perfect
pants the bunch of it and the foul David
just one of six shooting but he's made
plays like this push the tempo and
guarded very good mid-range player
[Music]
Augustine such a bit for the stuff and a
foul when he checks in a defensive
substitution and bounce pass to future
[ __ ]
puts it on his floor against Allen that
scores it from the left-handed layup
starting point guards but it's working
pretty well for him right now
Gooch of it's on the route entry from
Jonathan Isaac and with much of it
this is just a nice job to get it right
back in quickly and then pooch making
such a quick decision
Jonathan Simmons
[Applause]
kolja hobo vooc twitter probably google
it it's worth a look yep special person
Vuckovich on the drive and a foul just a
good job moving the bar the drive let's
go cheer for you you can always cheer
for yourself
and the young fella got turned around on
that play with the Wizards on top 11:00
at night they told a buncha [ __ ] a
couple of ball once in the cylinder you
can't mess with this but still in the
cylinder that's a push by Farid and a
three-point chance for Vukovich then the
double-team to helps not come in so
maybe keep couch out of the pick and
rolls running in storage and easy to go
through the back door 3-point nap sleep
matches their biggest good service with
the powerhouse Dan he plays David watch
Nikola boots a [ __ ] on the roll the
finish over [ __ ] of it follows with
less than one second to play in the
quarter
a 71 point first half for the magic
[Music]
[Applause]
they call the hoods of it's a all-star
break butcha [ __ ] is fouled by Marvin
Williams come the basket for the koala
reach of it's a great job little
pick-and-roll right here good hands good
catch passports to Augustine he throws
it away
followed by Gucci bitched to Augustin
puts it in off the glass
Amador's from the pokévision
we don't just want to bake from the
fourth imagine forceps
bucho [ __ ] here's that halo action
again and who that is fouled on the shot
firing lives
see ladies malice really kind of out of
position ends up going here and much of
its rejects toxin and saves it from
going out of balance and no more
turnovers got a value the basketball
court with the shot clock ticking down
in the game down as good as Isaac Ben
tonight
boots tips it away boots with the
deflection grant with the steal
three-point shot the number one pick has
been good to the mansion and times been
very good for the Cavaliers now there
was an interesting note on that first
graphic that I would like to see again
the teams that have never had but not
long enough
Allatoona stolen by the magic bucho
[ __ ] poked it away augustine strong
drive right-handed or she chopped now
Tyler Dorsey founded by isaac drops it
inside the Valentino's swatted away by
boot servers Holliday bounced it to
nowhere picked on - the bouncing at a
head to form a pretty nice maybe we
should let Joey call our flight of the
game everything thanks look from Isaac
to boot revenge
he'll take it against bumper nicely done
by Vukovich have to be careful Butler
will pull the chair out from under you
and splits the pair we're on the right
wing and watch Johnson turns his head
west right there on the cutting out it's
even furniture over while eating lasagna
on the attack was denied by Vukovich
Gordon formed a pretty two-man game he
needs a big finish tonight and Wednesday
in Charlotte but that is pretty amazing
JT it definitely is each of its deep and
the posts for the magic rabbit hole goes
all the way to the other end of in your
thumbs Roger that's pretty good
information good stop
Butchie [ __ ] is back any lumps in a
fadeaway jump third player in magic
history to average 20 and 10 in a season
bark is not a very good defender of
salad which is not nearly as physical go
to this
johnny is blue too [ __ ] five to shoot
for Gordon
[Applause]
which three the late
[Applause]
or new nobuta [ __ ]
kicks it out boss
three is gone
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content